I think this is a bit of an
intellectually cheap argument to say you
are a republican therefore the blood of
children is on your hands he supports
background checks as do I and I don't
think it's fair to just say because you
vote with one party therefore blood is
on your hands I think it's just it
contributes to the like polarization of
Republicans are evil Democrats are good
Or democrats are evil Republicans aren't
like you know you have to really think
when you align yourself with a party as
to what that party is doing for you your
family your country and the Republicans
in my opinion
right should be ashamed everything she
said there was backwards from the truth
the Uval shooter passed a federal
background check to get gun okay he got
the gun legally we do have checks and
you're going to have there's no such
thing as a perfect system humans are
imperfect so we build imperfect systems